the dog and his bone
a version of the tail by the
fablecottage.com
a dog is walking down the street when he
sees a bone in a trash can
a bone you pee how lucky for me he
thinks
he grabs the bone and happily runs home
he runs past the train station and the
school
he runs through the park
he runs onto a bridge
on the bridge the dog looks down into
the deep Still Water below
there he sees another dog with a bone in
its mouth
who is that dog he wonders
what is he doing down there
the dog stares at the other dog
the other dog stares back
where did that dog get such a big Bone
the dog wonders why is his bone bigger
than mine
the dog growls at the other dog
the other dog growls too
I want that big bone he thinks
the greedy dog decides to steal the
other dog's bone he leaps off the bridge
and into the water
[Music]
but as soon as he hits the water
the other dog disappears
there was never any other dog
it was just his own reflection
the water is very deep and the dog is
surprised
woof woof woof help he barks and when he
barks his bone drops from his mouth and
sinks to the bottom of the water
the dog swims to shore he is wet and
cold and now he has no bone at all
[Music]
moral
be happy with what you have if you're
greedy you might lose everything
thanks